foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday it's a haunting Mondays you guys
love these we love these yeah this is
one of our this is basically the our
favorite episode Spock is moving by
himself yeah
because I feel like I'm going off into
this I don't know I don't know if Pookie
did that or I don't know I haven't been
in here so all right
let me move you over a little bit oh
wait I'm okay oh yeah you're still in
there yeah you're still in there I'm in
the same place I'm always at you're the
one that's although like I said it seems
like we've drifted this way
well I don't know I didn't move the
camera or nothing like that hey
everybody look at Trey like a a new yeah
everybody's becoming membership and like
mango became a little membership welcome
to flash bulbs yeah thank you very much
there's only one tier and it's called
flash balls
okay
yeah I just put it there like I felt so
bad because because Trey like put a
message at the like a comment on under
one of the videos and he's like um I'm
really a dummy but I can't figure out
like how to join because I know you said
and I was just kind of like oh I guess
I'm the dummy because I filled all this
stuff out and then like there's a little
like in YouTube there's a little thing
at the top that says okay turn it on and
I forgot to push that so it was on but
it's on now so you know yeah
um so memberships are brand new thing
here on uh I thought I'm brand new but I
don't know how long they've been doing
it a while we didn't know about it okay
I mean I did but I I just never got to
turn around to doing it it's uh 2.99 a
month I think that's what it is right I
think yeah like I said there's only one
tear and it's just called flash balls
uh so yeah Tom Sykes says this episode
is legendary yeah a haunting roster yeah
I mean it's got to be like the best one
we've covered it we covered it back on
episode 39 before we even had a video
component yeah and we also did an
episode I think where we interviewed
um Craig naring I think his name is uh
from Fox paranormal or whatever who've
done a lot of like investigation around
the ruins and stuff but we just I don't
know it's like we like this episode and
we hadn't done it on this one and we
haven't knew a lot of new subscribers
since then that maybe didn't you know
hear the old one so and like I said I
didn't have a lot of time to
do a lot of research so I wanted to do
one that was kind of like a little bit
more familiar so we would have some
stuff to talk about and this is Tom's
favorite episode yeah I think it's the
best episode I think it is too um the
the two pilot episodes were pretty good
too when Mr Gordy and um
the one with the uh uh with the with the
kid with the cancer and the uh yeah with
the kid with the cancer yeah kid with
cancer and interference the snedeker
that was a good episode too
um but this is I think I think I think
this is the best one and then second to
this a little bit hungry ghosts I think
maybe we'll do that I mean we've done
that we've covered that a long time ago
yeah but I don't know that might be
another one worth doing because I really
like that episode too yeah
Trey says Mammoth Mountain's the best
episode one of them anyways
I know they should I kind of I talked to
him that was years ago yeah years ago
like they did call you yeah about doing
an episode well it was a haunting right
or was it or was it Paranormal Witness
haunting okay they cut they wanted to do
it but um Lois and red didn't want to
appear on camera yeah yeah they were
being a little yeah they were weird
looking they weren't looking good you
know [__] Lois had gotten fat and
[__] red was not feeling well and he
ended up dying later
and uh their house was filled with
[__] guitar cases and [__] because
red had
over the years I didn't know it but red
had kind of became a hoarder of [__]
famous guitars he was a guitar teacher
he had some of Stevie Ray Vaughan's
guitars he lived out California real
Wesley's got them all now
uh he had Eddie some of Eddie Van
Halen's guitars he had all kinds of uh
famous rock stars guitars there's
evidently a big trade in them
well yeah I didn't realize that but
there's a big collector trade in it and
it was just guitar cases just stacked
everywhere and some of them were guys
that weren't real well known but some of
them were you know well known to not to
the public but to guys that are you know
big into you know like the [__]
guitarist from [__] Quiet Riot maybe
like one of his you know I mean like I
don't even know that dude's name you
know that kind of [__]
Tom Sykes says the house they used in
this episode was a little too nice to
look abandoned in my opinion yeah we I
think we got into that maybe like before
the the house they used on here like
looks like a little bit slightly dumpy
but like still livable looks like a
southern meditation Mansion kind of
whereas it's a real house yeah I mean at
least when they took a photograph of it
like I think when the henshaws first
moved in it looked uh significantly
dumpier than it did on the show now I
think the photographs that that they
have are had on the internet of it were
after they had all they had moved out
yeah see I can't really figure that out
because there was if there is a
photograph floating around out there
where there's a couple people like in
the doorway and they're kind of like
waving but I can't like tell who it is
so I don't know if it's just some random
[__] that are like hey
Summerwood Mansion it's haunted because
it's like kind of famous or if that was
a picture that the family took like when
they moved in like Hey we're gonna fix
this place up you know what I mean
because I kind of feel like
it had to have looked like not that bad
I mean at least the way they were
talking about it now they did say that
it looked the the daughter
that was on the show April she said I
think she was eight or nine and like
when they moved into the house and she
said she actually used the word decrepit
she said that's she said it looked she
said she couldn't imagine anybody living
in it yeah so maybe it did look really
bad yeah because they're talking about
70s and uh the photographs it looks like
they're from the early 80s Maybe 83.
85 that period
and no it's a [__] dump it yeah it's
[__] up it's not painted it looks like
just raw wood the architecture really
sucked
um
it looked like a cheap knockoff of some
kind of Bavarian
[__]
hunting lodge mixed with a
I don't know
uh
I don't know there's no way to describe
it matter of fact the guy says it was
like a mixture of a bunch of
architectural Styles you couldn't put
your finger on it it just looked bad and
if you ask me and and um looking at it I
think it was made with pretty kind of
substandard wood because it would look
like it was warped water damaged
it wasn't built to last I don't think I
think it was made in the 20s right 30s
it was either 1916 or 1918 1980 it was
built and the thing about it was that I
kind of feel like I mean the people that
built it which we'll get into in a
little bit but you think it's in
Wisconsin yeah and you would think that
you know because it snows a lot there
and stuff like that that they would try
to at least build it you know up to
standards so that it would last through
the weather and everything but I don't
know it's just
it was hard to tell because I never saw
any photos of it when it looked good I
did you know they had some photos of it
I think for both black and white photos
yeah yeah it looked good but it you know
it was white yeah from what I remember
and it was
but you know it was it was in terrible
condition when they would when they
moved into it and nobody wanted it
and uh it was just filled with debris
inside it looked like squatters were in
there you know and people kicked holes
in the walls and uh busted sinks down
and
and the the materials that it was made
out of looks cheap it looked like
something out of an old camper or
something it it looked like a camping
Lodge a really big camping lot I think
that's what it was built as a fishing
line yeah like kind of a fancy yeah
fishing license Resort type thing yeah
but it looked it it didn't look like it
was uh
built to last
they look you know looked like it was
[__] made out of [__] cheap
material if you ask me yeah because
1920s or early 1910s that's that's no
big dealer houses uh all around from the
1800s they still look great yeah that
are still so I think it was just their
used cheap wood untreated wood or
something because it looked like things
had been warping and bow and
Zach said I'd love to know the address
of that house on the show because it's a
gorgeous looking home and always looked
like something in Southern California to
me yeah I mean the yeah the house they
look they used on the show like looked
like it was in pretty good shape it
looked like they just kind of like well
let's like throw some junk out in the
front so it kind of looks like it's in
Shady conditions yeah it also looks like
it's on a road too and it looks like
there's other houses near it the real
Summer Winds is like uh like a lodge and
it's out in the woods not well not
anymore it's not because like the ruins
of it I was watching a thing from a
couple of years ago where there was like
a paranormal team yeah and they went out
there to the ruins and they were doing
like the audio and everything and the
girl there the woman that was doing it
she's like um she's like well you can't
be too loud and stuff like that because
there are actually houses they're pretty
close yeah so she like turned around
like that and there was like a big
massive cabin like just right there
because when it was originally built it
was built on an 80 acre plot hot But as
time went on like like Parcels of land
got sold off you know what I mean like
to pay to keep the house running so
um so it doesn't have that much land
around it anymore but now it's pretty
much I mean where the house used to be
because all that's left there I don't
know if you know is like the chimneys
and like just some debris and [__] like
the basement and then it's mostly just
kind of like you know grown over but
there are houses like right around there
like cabins and [__] because it's on a
lake so
yeah I saw the uh an overhead view of it
from uh what do you call it Google Earth
long time ago their houses on either
side of it and behind it is a
uh is a lake
but from the old photos of the 80s of
the outside of it and the exterior there
was just it was in a clearing in the
thicket of a bunch of pine trees
um
I don't know how old the houses are
around it now they might have been from
the 90s or the 80s I don't know but one
of the comments I saw online when they
were talking about people that knew the
area
they didn't think it was burned down by
a lightning strike they think that's
[__] that it was the people of that
area went down there and [__] torched
it
because it was attracting
teenagers and [__]
yeah I mean I've heard that too I'm
pretty much like every other video you
see about it says about the same thing
yeah it's like you know officially it
was lightning but now they went in there
and torched and got rid of it
but it was just a Hulk at that point
and it was kind of a
it was an attraction for a bunch of
[__] teenagers want to [__] spray
pentagrams and [__] and get high in
there and you know that just and it was
bothering the neighbors so they just got
rid of it yeah
yeah Hugo said um yeah I wanted to
mention this because uh Lisa Loring the
OG Wednesday Adams died okay yeah guy
was like yeah I think I met her at a
horror convention several years ago but
yeah I just saw that like about an hour
ago she was what probably in her 70s I
don't know actually I mean she was a
little girl like on that show but
probably in her 60s that's [__] up
that's [__] up
that happens to everybody well I know
that
really you can't avoid it
64. 64 that's how old she was yeah I was
like I knew she couldn't be that old
because she was uh you know just a kid
yeah when she started that out uh Tom
Sykes says 69. everybody else says 64. I
don't know I don't know which one it is
but yeah
um so we got a few Ginny dug up a few
new details about this case too so it's
gonna be a good show yeah I mean you
know a few and it's not like I dug all
them because I didn't have a lot of time
today but like I said that's kind of
like why I wanted to do a case we were
more familiar with uh but yeah I watched
a couple other things about it there is
actually like a couple other good videos
about this but a lot of them are just
kind of like repeating stuff that was on
a haunting episode which is probably
what we're gonna do but I'm also
um gonna I found some stuff on another
website and there was some stuff that
that even the Hinshaw family because
there were other families that lived
there too like the people that built it
and stuff that also allegedly support
supposedly like reported Paranormal
Activity also but you know the haunting
episode was just about the Hinshaw
family
and there was even some stuff that they
supposedly saw that they didn't put on
the show for whatever reason I'm not and
I'm not really sure why because one of
the things I was like oh that would have
been really creepy I don't know why they
didn't put that on and I was the the guy
the dad that bought the house afterward
like he wrote a book about it you know
what I mean so I think a lot of the
stuff comes from that you know what I
mean yeah I kind of had my own theories
about what had happened I I remember
thinking that this was may have been a
real
paranormal case in the because it's two
stories yeah The Haunting and then the
dad comes and tries to investigate it
and rebuy the house right
I've always kind of suspected that maybe
something paranormal had happened there
but then the dad wanted the house and I
think he thought he would maybe he'd be
able to make money off of doing ghost
tours because he wanted to make it a a
hotel yeah or like a b and b or
something yeah right and he might have
played up some of the ghost angles but
so it's kind of like two different
things two two different stories in this
story
the first one I believe I'm not so sure
I believe the second one that much
or it might have been just maybe you
know maybe the second part of the story
The Second Story might be fairly
accurate but just kind of
exaggerated a little bit okay
the the whole uh land deed angle and uh
hypnosis and but you know it is an
interesting story and it's a real good
episode
I noticed too like while I was
um taking notes because I was actually
like writing the notes down by hand like
while you're watching it because I knew
that I wasn't going to have time to like
just re-watch the episode and type it
today so I was like watching it last
night and I was like sometimes it's
easier to take notes on the episodes
because like not much happens you know
what I mean and it's like so I have time
to write stuff down and then just like
somebody walks down a hallway forever
and so I was like oh okay thank you but
um this one so much stuff happens that I
was just like I was writing like really
fast because there's like always
something going on they didn't really
like [__] around too much in this one
there was like always something yeah
watching this one's like watching a good
movie
yeah it's like watching a good movie it
really is I mean and it's kind of
there's something about this one that's
kind of compelling you know uh makes me
think that
at least the first part of it happened
in uh
and yeah maybe they kind of spice it up
for the program
but still it's a good talent of it
it's just a good episode yeah
all right so you want to talk about the
episode I got all my little notes right
here and then I got more notes over
there good because you know how I do I
gotta have all of it all right all of it
uh and like I said I didn't really have
time to type this today
so yeah so this house let's just talk
about the henshaws first because that's
what the episode was about and then
we'll kind of go back and
talk about the other people that lived
there before and like how it got built
and stuff like that so yeah the house is
um West Bay Lake Wisconsin is where it
is
so they move into Summerwind in 1969 the
henshaws
now apparently Ginger Hinshaw who was on
the show much older lady
she
um I think even at that point like the
house was known as kind of like ooh the
haunted house around town you know what
I mean it was kind of like one of those
you know famous for being haunted like
places in Wisconsin right
so Ginger was with a friend of hers and
they're like oh we need to go back and
go and look at this haunted house or
whatever and ginger apparently
she said that she really really
um was drawn to it like immediately she
said it it had it gave off this really
weird vibe like you wanted to help it or
you wanted to like rescue it and it's
weird because like her dad kind of said
the same thing like later on so I was
like I don't know if they were trying to
imply that like maybe the house had some
kind of like weird
power over people where it was just kind
of like hey come and live in me and then
you know so I can [__] you over you know
what I mean I'm not really sure if
that's what they're replying but she was
basically saying that
she got completely obsessed when she saw
it she's like I had to have that house
she's like I just wanted to fix it I
wanted to
you know so you get a obsession over the
house yeah she said she felt sorry for
it and she wanted to like fix it she did
have obsessions over the house but the
colors and everything trying to really
take it back exactly what it was
thank you
yeah and that's that's like I said that
was something that they brought up like
more than once and she admitted that too
she was like I just I had to have it you
know what I mean
um she's like even though it obviously
probably didn't look all that great
so uh so yeah now her husband at the
time Arnold Mr where is that raccoon
himself
we're gonna We may be gonna be using
that audio clip a lot of this episode
um but yeah so he owned like a
construction company or something like
that he was like a contractor
and so she brought him to see it
and um he was like yeah we could
probably do something with that I don't
think they were gonna open it because I
think later on like when her dad bought
it like I think he was gonna turn it
into like a bed and breakfast or a hotel
or something I think I mean they were
just gonna live in it like ginger and
Arnold were just gonna live in it
because they had six kids I think they
said I thought on the show they said
four but then everywhere else I saw that
they had six so I'm assuming they had
six kids one of them April who I believe
was eight or nine at the time she was
the only like adult
um you know kid that was on there
talking about it
so
even though uh Ginger is like super into
the house and she said she just loved it
immediately and got obsessed with it and
everything April
um she said I did not like that house
like from the first time I saw it so
like it looked um real decrepit and like
Dusty and gross since like I really did
not want to be there it gave me like bad
vibes
so uh they've moved in
about a month and they got all moved in
and everything so it's like I said I
guess it was I guess you could live
there I mean because they were living in
it
so Arnold and ginger like work on the
house they're doing a lot of the work
themselves because like I said Arnold is
a contractor
and Ginger's in there like she was
talking about all the stuff she was
doing like all the painting and she put
in the um you know the new fireplace and
all this other kind of stuff she's like
but the weird thing was that they
noticed that they would call
um you know service workers and stuff
like that like to come out and fix stuff
or come and look at stuff and everything
and they're just like yeah sure we'll do
that and then they're like where you
live and then they say where they live
and they're like uh yeah we're kind of
like busy and we can't really do that
right now you know what I mean so they
thought it was like really weird that
people kept blowing them off once they
found out what house they lived in now
we speculated before that we don't
necessarily know if that's just because
all these service workers were like
superstitious and they're like we're not
going in the haunted house no no thank
you or if they were just like well that
place is a piece of [__] and I don't
even really want to deal with it so it
could have been that because like I said
it was I mean I'm not sure exactly what
the condition of the house was in 1969
1970 when they were calling these people
to work on the way he put it he said
yeah I'd get some teams that would go
yeah we don't normally handle something
that big maybe we can put you in next
year that kind of thing I think what the
contractors wanted is they wanted to
have like short high profit jobs they go
in they work four or five days and then
they move on to the next one and they
probably end up making more profit over
time they look at a big old house like
that and they're like oh man there's so
much work there we'll bleed those people
dried about three weeks and then then
it'll be all over and the job won't even
be you know 1 8 done that's probably
what it was they're like these people
don't have the money to fix that that's
probably what it was that might have
been yeah because one of the things that
I was watching another show about it and
uh or like an interview you read an
interview about it what's that Focus
um or like listening to a podcast about
it and the guy was like that was one
thing that a lot of people like would
move into the house everybody would come
and see this like ooh they all this
potential like all the stuff they wanted
to do with it but it's like they would
never realize like how much much money
it was going to take like to fix the
[__] up yeah I mean I think they were
just kind of like everyone was like oh I
can do this and that and the other it
had been cheaper just to buy a new house
that's what I mean it's probably like a
lot of times when it's something like
that unless it's something super super
historical and you're gonna get you know
what I mean and you want it fixed up I
get that but it's just like if it's just
a house that's just a house yeah big old
man old [__] cabin really like it
looks like a little temporary Ski Lodge
uh turned into like a mansion-sized ski
lodge really what it looked like to me
yeah I just kind of feel like at that
point you might as well just like knock
it down and yeah start over it just
didn't look it was built to last and the
style didn't look that good
what I mean now you don't have to worry
about it because now it's like
except for the chimneys because that was
the only thing that made out of that was
made out of stone or brick or whatever
the hell
so uh so yeah
now one day uh while Ginger is working
in the house
she finds allegedly uh The house's
original blueprints like stuck in a
closet or in a wall it's in a closet
something or something in the closet
yeah and uh because well because I I'm
thinking of like other things where like
I saw another interview and they said oh
it was like in the wall like she found
it on the wall but like I said I don't
know
um now apparently this blueprint was
wrapped around a piece pipe which ties
in with a story that they supposedly
found out later on
um and she said from finding that she
said then I started to become super
obsessed with putting the house back
exactly the way it was before
and she said particularly like the paint
colors and all this other kind of stuff
like she she said on the show it's like
oh I went through like 11 different
paint colors to get like the perfect one
and stuff although one I don't think
they mentioned this on a haunting but on
um one of the other things that I read
one of the things they said was that and
I'm guessing this was in
the dad's book
was that yeah she was doing all the
stuff with the paint colors but they
would paint the walls and then like the
old color would keep bleeding black back
through you know what I mean like they
could like they couldn't get anything to
take and so I don't know it's like to me
it's like I don't know if that was what
was going on but I was like that really
doesn't seem like Paranormal no it's not
wrong that just seems like maybe you
didn't prime it or not I don't really
know I'm not really sure like what color
you were trying to paint over kind of
old-fashioned paint mix not mixing well
with new with new style maybe that's
what it was or you know maybe the walls
were red or something like that which is
because like still bleeds through even
though you put because I tried to paint
over like a red wall one time and like
you had to put like I think I had to put
three or four coats of primer on that
[__] and it was still looked kind of
pink but yeah
um so yeah so she's putting it back uh
exactly the way it is now Arnold like I
said
uh Mr where's that raccoon he um
yeah I was just gonna do it I was gonna
do it I gotta find it
that actually plays that guy the actor
that plays that guy is awesome in there
you go out there and find that record
right now I don't care I don't care
he's so angry yeah yeah I don't care I
mean he he leaned into it and I was like
I respect that decision I mean it was a
memorable performance that's for sure I
got that shot at him of the damn camera
zooming in on him he's looking all
stressed out what do you want what do
you want what do you want
he goes keep coming in on him that was
[__] great what do you want
that's kind of like the way the bad
house was that that yeah it was kind of
that's kind of the way it felt yeah
oh look mango uses my little where's
that raccoon like that emoji
I think the Tom one is I think it's you
put Colin Toms Blaine colon and I think
that I think that's what it is I can't
remember what I named it I think it was
Thompson
Lane I tried to name everything like
shorts you could like remember
and then like one of them is Pookie like
that's Pookie sighting yeah and what's
the other one smell of sanctity that's
right smells sanctity yeah it's like a
little Rose that's the Tom's playing one
see it's like look it's you let me see
hold on
like he even he even has like a little
black wife beater on I can't really see
it it's too small
it says Tom's plane it looks like a
little tiny geometric shape almost it's
like yeah it's a little tiny top okay
it's a little tiny top cool well you can
probably see it a lot better like on a
big yeah because you just have like a
little bitty thing
so uh so yeah so Arnold seemed like he
was kind of into it at first like
helping out and everything but uh before
too long he just loses interest in [__]
and much like Tom's doing right now
no I'm thinking I just thought that was
funny that like the second I said that
you're like turning around like what I
got a cat there yeah okay
um
yeah so he just like loses interest and
just starts like leaving jobs unfinished
and stuff he's like yeah whatever yeah
she said he'd do things and he wouldn't
do things and just walked around looking
at stuff I think I even wrote that in my
notes I said he just walks around that
room's looking at [__] that's what I
wrote
standing on the brand I'm looking
outside and then looking back in
[Laughter]
became creepy and then he stopped
talking to him wouldn't talk to him yeah
we'll get into that yeah we'll get into
that it must have went evil
yeah and like I said the actor did a
good job gotta say
so uh so yeah so Ginger said that she
started to notice some minor paranormal
activity in the sense where I don't know
how minor this is but um chairs kind of
moving by themselves like when her back
was turned [__] like that
um April the daughter she said she
always felt watched Ginger said she felt
like that too like this she always felt
like somebody was in the room with her
um but she loves the house so much that
she doesn't want to believe that it's
haunted they did a a scene in the
reenactment here where she was in that
creepy hallway like the hallway of Doom
there and um she's just like walking
through there and I guess they kind of
had it where she heard like breathing or
you know that noise they always do on a
haunting where it's like that like kind
of noise like um yeah like so she kind
of heard that but I don't know she saw
anything at that point she does see
something later in the hallway she she
sees apparitions twice at least twice
yeah it's like several people did report
seeing apparitions in this particular
house
and the weird thing about it is that
some of the ones they reported saying
like I don't think they showed it on the
show or like what the people described
it looked like like in other sources
okay but you know exclusive
[Laughter]
yeah okay uh so yeah so weeks go by and
here's the fun part because Arnold
starts to turn into like Mega douche
right Mega douche 2000 yeah
um he just gets really withdrawn his
personality completely changes he starts
sleeping all day playing that [__]
organ all night yeah they're gonna stop
doing it I like it
no I want I want to stop playing it will
you please stop too no
yeah that was a little bit well the
first the First dress organ music that
he's sucking I know I think I've read in
my notes I said his organ plan goes all
Carnival Souls yeah
when I first when I first when I first
saw this I saw it on cable TV I guess
that was around 2008 around that time
and uh it spooked me out man this and I
saw for the first time uh it was up in
Sorrento Springs you know Sorrento
Springs uh like going to going to the
club yeah
in that in that townhouse I used to live
in this area [__] over what 15 years
ago 14 years yeah and it was nice nice
new
um a place called Sorrento Springs
it still looks nice but uh I was
upstairs and had cable installed and
everything and
during the daytime is when I was running
that Barn
and as I got done with the feeding and
[__] got all the horses [__]
settled and then went back home to chill
out until the evening to [__] bring
them all back in and I was watching
haunting episodes this is long before I
met Jenny
and that and [__] that episode they
would play him I think it was on a e was
it
[Music]
it was on
Discovery before that yeah
but they'd play them back to back man
they play like seven of them and I saw
that one and it [__] spooked me out
the whole rest of the day that [__]
damn organic I like it
no leave me alone
[Laughter]
shutting the bar down putting them up
[__] no Sun's going down [__] me
thinking about that damn ghost man
have that dude playing that word yeah
yeah
I don't think they mentioned this in the
episode but I think one of the reasons
that he gave apparently for playing the
organ all the time was that he thought
that if he stopped something really bad
would happen oh he gave he gave that
reason well I don't know if that or I
don't know if he gave that reason or if
like ginger said that like in some other
place I don't think they mentioned that
on the show but I heard that somewhere
else so like I said that might have been
her talking like in another interview or
her dad's book or something like that
all right but I heard that mentioned on
an in another source that he thought
that something bad would happen if he
stopped okay so that's that's another
dimension
Yeah you mentioned that story okay he
was keeping the spirits at Bay yeah I
guess that's what he was doing
so that's why he was like up all night
doing that [__]
um but the first thing that he started
because he did that like he started that
at first but um yeah he just started
getting like real real angry and one of
the first things was that he was outside
working on the house and like two of the
daughters were out on the porch like
fighting around with Barbies or whatever
and um he's like what which one of you
girls suck my hammer and they're like
why the [__] could we take your Hammer
you know what I mean this is that they
didn't say that because they were little
kids but you know what I mean
um but that was what they meant so why
the [__] would we take her hey what's up
will somebody took it it's not here
anymore blah blah and he was just like
wigging out about it
and he was like screaming at him about
that [__] and then
um he goes in the house why is this
window open this window's always open
it's like just like I don't [__] know
I didn't open it I want it closed yeah
and it's like apparently it used to open
by itself all the time that's what they
were saying it's like that window is
always [__] open like you can she's
like I don't know I didn't open it and
he's like well somebody's opening it and
it's like she's like fine I'll just nail
it shut just to get you to shut the [__]
up you know what I mean yeah so it was
that kind of thing but yeah they did say
that that window would like be open all
the time like there was no way you could
keep it closed so finally they had to
nail it shut so one of the other sources
said that Arnold nailed that [__] but I
don't really know like who somebody
nailed it should anyway
so yeah so as we mentioned before Arnold
that that uh stage kind of stopped
talking to everybody
and just sort of like walks around the
rooms like staring at [__] and you know
uh lyric and just yeah like walking in
the room and I'm looking creepily at
them they're just like bro I want that
job
all right Mia come to your house to walk
around your house every time I see you
know
get a scowl on my face just get down
there in the doorway yeah keep your arms
crossed to keep you all motivated and
then I walk away
20 minutes later I come back in a check
at all
crazy people paid me like 50 Grand a
year to do that
I mean hey I need a mentally ill Rich
dude that does that I mean I will pay
people to come over and snuggle with
them so it's like I don't see why that
would be any weirder you can have Ming
the merciless show up and just be mean
to you without saying a word that's you
know what maybe there maybe there's a
thing in there yeah put on my merciless
outfit right somebody pay for that I bet
yeah people pay for all kind of crazy
[__]
people pay for likes girls man they'd
want to beat off on you while you were
doing it [__] well yeah yeah I mean that
would be an occupational hazard I'm
afraid
Dude tell you keep moving
turn around
squish your hips
okay look we gotta get back
yeah that's who did that you did that
you did it on you
if everything's my fault
so uh more smooth
your life goes more smoothly
all right so uh so yeah so one day uh
Ginger hears what she called a strong
male voice calling her name in the
creepy hallway of Doom yeah so that is a
pretty creepy hallway no you're not
gonna lie
so it keeps like saying her name over
this which would be pretty freaky like
if you're walking with a ginger it's
like that right and uh so she turns
around and she does actually see an
apparition she did say she saw an
apparition right she saw no when it said
Ginger yeah when she was going up the
stairs she just heard that yeah I see
anything that later she was going down
the hallway and I think she heard it say
ginger and she turned around and it
passed through her she saw it in the pet
she saw like they just showed us like
smoke like a face with sort of like a
face kind of a face and it went through
her and she said it just passed right
through her yeah which is pretty freaky
yeah
so uh so yeah that's how it was shown in
the episode yeah they're not she
actually said that a lot of times
there's a difference they just do it for
like to do a sit they do a [__]
action version of it for all we know it
was at the end of the hallway and it
didn't move through her at all or
something I don't know I mean that would
still be scary like if it was standing
there yeah you know what I mean that's
still seeing an operation
so uh so yeah at this point in the
episode we get to uh Arnold going turbo
douche uh and this is the where is that
raccoon uh segment of the show yeah that
raccoon's dead that's where it is well
now it is because of Arnold yeah yeah
apparently what had happened was that
the raccoon they had a pet raccoon and
it got out and whether or not this was
the case he blamed the girls for leaving
its enclosure open right and like
letting it Escape
and so he's like it's like night time
and he says to his wife he's like well
they're gonna go out in the woods and
find that raccoon right now and she's
like it's the middle of the night I
don't care I don't care if they're gonna
find that button yeah and then that
raccoon yeah
where is that raccoon yeah so so yeah so
he goes and finds it apparently I don't
know if the girls found it or he found
it but he killed it in front of them
yeah and the daughter said that too yeah
[__] that dude needed a serious assby
weapon out of whip that motherfucker's
ass well yeah I mean that's it came back
and he kills it who kind of you know
either that or he went out specifically
to find it so he could bring it back and
kill it like who the [__] does that
crazy people it's just yeah you [__]
crazy [__] that's who I'm just going
out having a good time
you know that's what I mean and the
thing about her friendly Little
Creatures yeah they're real friendly
here it's all right yeah yeah I can't
even imagine the kind of person that
would like kill
just to be like a douche yeah to punish
some girl yeah it's terrible
yeah their pet for Christ's sake I can't
imagine yeah you need to be doing it for
food that's one thing and if it's not
your pet you know what I mean it's a
wild animal you know right and you know
it's yeah I gotta get some food man
[__] not make it a groceries the show
hell yeah
but uh no just to make a point on a pet
and it's a little girl's pet you man you
need a serious ass weapon and is it in
as a little raccoon yeah he's probably
like it's a pet raccoon probably yeah
with their little heads yeah they beg
and put on shows and showing myself out
yeah
I was trying to like I was trying to
like make it funny but it's not funny
it's like like I said they got those
little fizzle hands and it's like no
that's terrible
uh but yeah so Ginger is just kind of
like uh trying to maintain some normalcy
which you know good luck with that
but she apparently invites some friends
over one night a couple that she knows
and
um she goes in the kitchen to get some
cheese and crackers because it's the 70s
y'all and that's what you did you went
and got cheese and crackers for your
friends
um and while she's in the kitchen she
hears somebody say her name again like
uh you know somebody's name like you
know the the man's voice
so then she hears her friend
screaming in the living room
and she runs in there and the woman just
saw like a they saw an apparition like
in the corner of the living room
and she screamed and then they just got
the [__] out they were like yeah no bye
nice to visit you but you have ghosts in
your [__] house and we're not having
it so yeah they just ran right the [__]
out of there
so yeah so at this point like I said
Arnold's organ playing this is what I
wrote Arnold's organ playing goes all
Carnival of Souls yeah and he plays all
goddamn night that's what I wrote
I'm keeping everyone awake
uh Ginger tells him to cut it out but no
he likes it he likes playing with his
organ
um
it doesn't give a [__] about keeping
everybody awake people that got to work
in the morning people got to go to
school in the morning he's just like he
moves I don't care I like it yeah that's
what he says
um and at this point April who like I
said was about nine years old I think
when this was going on she said she
really got the impression that Arnold
hated all of them and hated ginger in
particular yeah and they said she said
he wasn't like that before yeah it was
this way at the house yeah he just went
down and he lost his own business and
wouldn't go to work and
there's a couple different explanations
Maybe
the stress of owning that home and
fixing it
um put him into some kind of depression
he lost his job and went crazy and then
blamed them
or it was some kind of weird form of
possession you know I don't know
I've never seen any I've never seen
possession as far as I can I'm concerned
possession is just a different
interpretation of poltergeist
um but this is not a poltergeist this is
this is haunting
Steve Merritt believes it you know he
said he's seen a few of them
um
but it's not you know I've seen the bad
house so maybe it's like that but it's
strong enough to move things
and and have apparitions so I can
imagine it
maybe it can affect your mind I mean it
was affecting our minds
they're giving us bad dreams
you know so
Maybe
and maybe drive you crazy and maybe he
wasn't like super stable to begin with
right so you found him as a weak a weak
link right
could be yeah I took advantage of him or
something turned him to evil or his
reaction to it was to become evil
I don't know weird weird [__]
yeah so apparently it was getting so bad
in the house that Ginger starts sleeping
out in the [__] Woods like around the
house like instead of sleeping which is
that that's pretty extreme yeah I
remember when I first saw that wow man
this story's got to be true
burning the furniture I could imagine
well that's what I was saying because
it's like Arnold like like I said he's
just like playing the organ all the time
Zach says damn he must be using a lot of
lube to make that much sound while
playing this organ
right I don't care I like it
man I should have had an audio clip for
that yeah okay I like it
if you want what do you want
what do you want from me I mean you
could just do it yeah yeah we've seen
this episode so many times and it's like
he got the inflection right and
everything yeah but so yeah so he's like
not even going to work anymore because
he's too busy sleeping and playing the
organ all night
so uh so they're basically running out
of money you know yeah and uh so they
all sleep in the living room like in
front of the fireplace uh the gas gets
shut off the electric gets shut off
um the water pump breaks and they have
to bring water from the lake like to
take baths and flush the toilet and
stuff and they have to start burning all
the furniture like to keep warm which
you know that's like that's pretty
[__] up
so at this point uh you know Arnold's
coming in like I said they're all
sitting around the the fireplace where
they're burning all the chairs Arnold
comes in and like [__] scowls at them
like standing there and they're just
like what the [__] Dad it's like that's
not cool uh so finally Ginger just says
[__] it and she walks to the neighbor's
house and calls her dad and says please
come get us I'm sick of this [__]
uh so the kids were super super happy
because they were like holy crap we're
getting the [__] out of here finally
because like I said April said that she
and one of the younger sisters too who
wasn't uh interviewed on the show she
said they had actually like contemplated
suicide like they were at like nine and
eight and nine years old trying to
escape the street because they said it
was just so [__] horrible and so
stressful all the time
so they were just like so happy they
said it was like getting out of [__]
prison like they get to go with Grandpa
Grandpa comes with his camper and
they're like we're out of here you know
yeah now this is basically the first
part of the story yeah and there's
something about this maybe because my
experience at that bad house which is
not really the Poltergeist you know not
Mammoth but the one the one in um uh
um right outside of Somerville I think
was Arlington
uh near Boston
and um
it wasn't this bad but I could kind of
imagine that maybe this is plausible I
kind of take this first part of the
story
plausible it's the claims are not that
incredible
apparitions
voices
feelings of being watched
uh the one dude goes crazy
and they said like chairs I'd move yeah
and yeah and like windows open Windows
and that that
yeah that's what that's within the realm
of kind of [__] that I've experienced
yeah that's not really all that crazy I
mean you know relatively it's just the
setting the way it's shown and way it's
told in this in this episode it's
[__] very compelling it sticks with
you and playing the organ and everything
it's just and the uh the family being in
uh totally just beaten down by this
oppressive evil feeling inside this
house and their dudes losing his mind
there's almost like kind of something
like out of The Shining slightly well
yeah I mean that would be really super
scary like even if you weren't going
through paranormal [__] like if you were
stuck in this house with like a dude
that was like going insane and you
didn't know what the [__] he was gonna
do I mean that would be like really
frightening like you said it is kind of
like the shame and like an added creepy
scene they all get in the Winnebago to
leave and the dude what's his name again
Arnold Arnold Arnold sitting up in the
top
window up in the top floor looking out
the window watching him go he's just
sitting there watching him go and then
it says he leaves the next day
so he spent the night in there by
himself
then it says Ginger and the kids never
hear from him again yeah now they did
not mention this on the show but some
other sources that I saw yeah said that
the next day I don't know if the if the
butter of men with the butterfly Nets
came got him or if he went and committed
himself but apparently he went to a
mental hospital okay the following day
okay so they didn't mention that on the
show they just said he leaves the next
day
okay bloody blah I don't know if that's
true or not I'm just saying I saw some
other sources that said that it sounds
plausible that he went to like a mental
because he was acting like a [__]
nice so he might have thought he went
crazy well he did go crazy I guess yeah
that's what I'm saying maybe she told
him you need to go get help and he
just got right he goes to mental
hospital
weird
which I don't have anywhere else to go
either that's true he did he didn't have
any money
you're gonna that'd be a trip if they
just left his ass in there no money he's
just squatting in there yeah trying to
survive in this [__] haunted house by
himself [__] playing that organ well
they couldn't play the organ because
there was no power by that point
remember the power got cut yeah so man
that'd be a trip and then like years
later he's walking years later he'd come
out and he'd look like he had like big
long fingernails like I was gonna say
like a big beard and crazy hair and [__]
like that like with lace and stuff yeah
[Laughter]
his whole job for the past 30 years was
just walking around in that haunted
house by himself at night and freak
everybody out yeah freaking himself out
silent as [__] no [__] electricity
yeah that would be super just a wind
howling remember said that he could hear
the wind yeah look look by looking at
the structure of that house a lot of
that wind was [__] blowing through
the boards of the walls I think there
were spaces in between some of those
boys because it didn't start out being
called Summer Wind it only started being
called that like I think that the dad
named it that okay you know what I mean
like in the 70s okay prior to that it
was called the Lamont Mansion because
that was the name of the guy that built
it yeah like or the guy that paid for it
to be built now the part two of this
story involves Ginger's Dad yeah Raymond
Raymond all right now
Raymond actually in the interview seems
like a cool guy and then the actor that
they have play in him he's kind of cool
you know I like he's just like a cool
little guy you know I'm gonna figure
this on now
and then it kind of like you know make a
bed we're gonna make a buck off this he
kind of comes across that way but you
know yeah
yeah uh like for his generation kind of
a um
I would call him I don't want to he
seemed kind of like a conservative type
dude but he was like into like uh
paranormal and new agey kind of stuff
like you know
and then his son had just got him back
from Vietnam
and uh
was trying to help him rebuild this
house and he saw some [__]
so uh it's a pretty cool this this part
of the story is also cool
it gets it gets a little uh outside the
realm of my personal experience though
so I can't vouch for it I'm a little
more skeptical of certain elements of
this story
because I think there might have been
uh uh
some motive to uh spice the the story up
and get some traffic coming through that
house
maybe as a Britain back bread and bread
and breakfast
you get old you can't you lose
pronunciate
it's a bread and breakfast bread and
breakfast
you're coming my dad
next I'm gonna be thinking there's
turkey neck since
oh yeah oh well I mean you know that
happens to everybody like you said about
death yeah
cheer up uh yeah
so um so yeah so like I said what did we
say anything about your job interview
today no we haven't okay Jenny
landed a really good job today but this
is but it's a little far tomorrow she's
got another uh
it's about 45 minutes each way yeah
that's a game changing uh income there
um but she's got an interview tomorrow
it's a little bit more even and it's
only 15 minutes away
I think she's gonna get that one she's I
think she's gonna get them both well
we'll see I don't really know pressure's
off you don't have to get this one now
yeah you got it right you got one it's
like yeah the one I'm going to the
interview I'm going to tomorrow is
closer like it's about like 20 minutes
25 minutes something like that but like
yeah the other one was like 45 50
minutes yeah oh uh we were talking about
them living at that that dude walking
around at night and living in Summer
Wind and everything
for some reason it made me think of
you know how [__] cost these eggs are
going up one of the things I could do in
this house is give me a bird cage and
put quail in there they lay eggs or
little eggs yeah but it doesn't take
that many I was doing the research like
six I think like six or seven of those
Quail would probably lay us
you know probably four or five eggs a
day
they add up yeah that's true and if they
age out you let someone hatch you eat
some of those quails
and I think you can let them out see and
the Housing Commission it's not like
owning chickens
you couldn't they couldn't prove those
were yours they don't make they're quiet
yeah and uh some people let them go
during the day and they come back
oh okay and sleep in a sleep in the cage
oh and that's often as long as they're
getting fed they come back evidently
well yeah animals aren't dumb they're
not dumb there's like why would I wander
around out here and maybe get food when
I can for sure get food going in yeah
and then you have to feed them because
they're out feeding themselves yeah and
they're little yeah I've seen them and
they get too old you know I'll just
sneak a couple of them off and chop
their heads off nobody will even know
oh don't show the other equipment I
don't know so they don't know right and
let some of the eggs hatch you see what
happens with Sally she was just here
yeah
I'm gonna look into that
he won't let us they won't let us have
any chickens yeah they won't let you
have chicken they won't let you have
chickens people you know [__] I mean
you can have chickens around here but
not in this name not in this
neighborhood because they're like yeah
it's too right
I guess they think it's too noisy or
you're too noisy yeah or something
but yeah Quail you could maybe do that
Yep they're quiet
they're quiet doesn't anybody sell eggs
around here like chicken eggs probably
but I want them for free that's true and
once you get those once you get those
Quail roll and you you get free quail
see that's true
and if you're letting them go they're
feeding themselves
most of the day then you come back and
you give them some feed and bed them
down and just let them lay eggs
but I gotta find more about it they're
cheap
so use free food yeah
and it comes back
the [__] out of here didn't it come back
no yeah it's nice in here cookie would
trip the [__] out she probably was
you've had a big old a big old bird I
put put him in like a decorative bird
cage like your parents kind of right but
maybe once a little little Mike Tyson
likes to do that you know that pigeons
oh yeah yeah I didn't know Mike Tyson
raises pigeons how the [__] did I know
that I don't know yeah he loves pigeons
just one of those facts that I remember
yeah
speaking of yeah I was going to say that
the job interview I went to today was
like it's a dog friendly office so a lot
of people had their dogs at the office
today and one of the people there they
have a dog whose name is also Pookie
yeah which I thought was very funny but
I think these [__] Quail are
camouflage see because they don't look
domestic
all right you let them go and they just
look like wild animals they're [__]
camouflaged
[Laughter]
the HOA would never know those are my
coil eating other people's food
[Laughter]
those birds are too cool anyway they are
yeah how big are the eggs I don't think
I've seen the babies are probably about
that big but uh yeah because they're big
birds yeah I mean they're not as big as
ostrich or nothing but they're pretty
big they're like three or four feet tall
all right so where was I
okay so yeah so Ginger's dad comes in a
camper and picks her and the kids up
so she tells her dad about all the [__]
that happened she's like I told him
everything about what happened at the
house but um he didn't really believe it
he was just kind of like I don't really
believe in it for that I don't believe
in that paranormal stuff whatever
so in 1972 Ginger and the kids moved to
Ontario
now I should note I don't think they
mentioned this on the show but I found
this somewhere else because they said
that once the dad and the son had bought
the house and started working on it they
said well it had significantly
deteriorated and I said well how long
are we talking about like has it been
abandoned when um the hinshaws moved in
I believe it was 1969. I think they were
only there for six months and then I
don't think the dad bought the house
until at least 72. so it was maybe three
or four years that it was empty so that
was the sixth place okay yeah so it was
it at least three years that the house
was empty and like falling to ruin do
you know what I mean like before the dad
came so it was like in way worse shape
but and maybe longer I'm not sure
so um so at this point like ginger who
wasn't super into the Paranormal before
but now she's again become obsessed with
it because she's trying to like figure
out what the [__] happened in the house
right so she starts like studying all of
that stuff in depth and she's like I'm
never going back to that house ever
again but the dad in spite of himself uh
Raymond his name is
he becomes uh also obsessed with it and
he when he goes to look at the house he
said pretty much the same thing his
daughter said he said it looked like a
wet puppy like you just wanted to go
over and like Comfort it and help it and
so
so he's like um I'm gonna buy that [__]
he's gonna turn it into like a hotel
restaurant type situation a bread and
breakfast
have some bread listen to Beck yeah
party yeah no I don't I don't know that
doesn't sound like a good job well
eating bread sounds fun not listening to
back so much
um but yeah so as I mentioned the
condition of the house had significantly
deteriorated in the several years since
Ginger had lived in there hold on but
what oh I just wanted to mention yeah uh
about the job situation uh Jenny's job
will not really affect the show we got
subscribers where you know the shows
will continue to come especially
probably Monday haunting Wednesday and
Friday jitty may not put out the same
amount of pre-recorded reviews but you
guys really won't notice a big
difference on the show yeah I mean we
might have to move some of the live
streams to like later right like later
in the evening or we might have to like
move around a day or something like that
I don't know but we'll work it out there
but yeah yeah we'll figure it out yeah
because the hours if I you know if I end
up doing the one that's farther away
like the hours are eight to five so I
probably wouldn't be home until six six
or six thirty so yeah so we might like
have to to push the show back like an
hour or something like that but we'll
see how it goes we'll see how it goes
and like I said we might
move well obviously like if we're doing
weeknight shows like I can't drink as
much on you're right but because I don't
want to have to like wake up early the
next morning and be like ah I'd be like
hangover every day so that would suck
but I would still be able to drink on
the Friday night shows so that would be
okay
so uh so yeah so Raymond is the dad and
it's kind of confusing but the son who
is also Ginger's brother obviously uh
his name is Ray and like Tom mentioned
he just came back from Vietnam and he's
kind of looking he's also a contractor
so they're both looking for some big
project now they're not actually living
in the house they're actually living in
they have like a camper and it's like
parked on the property and they live in
that because I guess the house is not
livable at this point foreign
so they said like when they went in
there they felt like they said it felt
like weirdly cold in there
um and it just kind of just I don't know
it felt like weird and eerie and stuff
and he calls Ginger who like I said
doesn't live in Wisconsin anymore she's
moved to Canada at this point and he's
like oh guess what I bought that house
that you told me not to ever go into and
she is like completely completely she's
like why the [__] would you do that it's
like I told you all the [__] to happen
there like why and you just specifically
went and bought oh it'll be fine it'll
be fine Raymond kind of like blows her
off it's not haunted it's cool
um yeah and they said April who was a
kid at that time she was like I can't
believe Grandpa did that what a [__]
[__] he had a shoe didn't say that but
you know what I mean so they she was mad
too that like they bought the house
she's like I can't believe the house is
like evil what are you even doing there
so uh so the dad and the son have the
same problems with contractors not
wanting to come out to the house and fix
anything they said sometimes too like
when they would get stuff delivered I'm
assuming like you know supplies or
whatever they would just kind of like
leave them in the driveway and then like
take off like they wouldn't even come up
to the door and [__] they said yeah that
happened too
um Ray said that he heard growling the
first night like I said he's staying out
in a camper he's like that might have
been bears not entirely sure probably it
was
um the next day he's working in the
house alone
when something and you don't find out
what it is until later scares him so bad
that he basically just rushes out the
house and won't tell anybody what
happened like he goes back to his dad's
house and the dad's like well what are
you doing home I thought you were
working on Summer Wind today he's like
oh um you know the all the [__] broke
and I couldn't get anything done so I'm
just home and back off like leave me
alone you know what I mean so it was
that kind of situation but really it was
because he saw like some [__] up [__]
but he wouldn't tell anybody what it was
now
um here's the thing too because the dad
Raymond he got really interested in the
history of the house
so he asked a neighbor who apparently
knew some [__] about it like what was
going on with it now here's the weird
thing on the show they said that the
family that had built the mansion and
lived there like back in the early 20th
century were were called the Pattersons
that wasn't their name
um the actually the guy that built the
house was named Robert Patterson Lamont
so maybe that's what they were getting
at he was actually the U.S Secretary of
Commerce in 1916 and he built the house
initially like I said it was initially
80 acres and he um had con it had been
built as like a fishing lodge
uh there's like a bed and breakfast type
thing
that people would go to and fish because
it's right on a lake and he later moved
into it with his family and like
converted it into like living quarters
and then he also had like another little
house like on the property like where
this the servants lived now apparently
the servants uh thought the house was
haunted from the beginning uh that they
they would see apparitions and [__] like
that even way back then so the legend
goes
but the lamonts did not believe this
until
famously uh one particular night Lamont
and his wife are sitting in the kitchen
or the dining room or whatever like
having dinner and the basement door
starts like rattling and like opens by
itself and they apparently saw a dude
like uh like an apparition like come out
the basement and they knew it wasn't a
guy because they're like there's no way
they could be anybody in there so Lamont
apparently shot at the ghost because
what else are you gonna do yeah and then
I'd do it because well you never know
yeah
it might work
and then uh so the bullets went right
through it did make the ghost like
disappear in the uh in the episode they
show the dude open a damn drawer he's
always [__] early 1900s suit open up
a drawer and pull out a nice [__]
what's up
pull out a nice Colt 19 11 45 [__]
start open fire shoots two shots at it
but they got the gun
they got the right gun from the right
period
wow somebody was on the ball yeah doing
the reenactments yeah yeah it was cool
they did you got [__] 1911 was the
best thing that was the desert eagle of
the day
what's up
but yeah so the bullets apparently went
right through and you know left bullet
holes in the door famously and so uh at
that point I guess that was the first
time the Le Mans had seen anything and
they were like yeah we're out uh and
they basically just took off and left
the house
so um so that was the story that Raymond
heard from the neighbor
so Ginger goes up to visit her dad uh
goes to Wisconsin to visit her dad to
try to talk him out of this these
shenanigans
but he's like no no I already got plans
for this house look I heard he drew out
all the all the blueprints and
everything
now she notices that her brother Ray is
sitting over there like acting real
anxious she's like he's like biting his
nails and doing all this other stuff and
remember how I said that she was getting
real into like Paranormal stuff she's
like oh I've been getting really into
like hypnosis so do you want me to
hypnotize you so you can like chill out
or like see what your problem is
so she does it
and apparently like his legs start
shaking like really hard
and then they said his voice completely
changed like he was talking in somebody
else's voice and he kept saying like
creepy [__] like um he said I am strong
my children are strong you are weak I
thought I said his children were weak I
had seven children in there all week I
despised them yeah he was saying [__]
like that I am strong yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was doing I am strong
my children are weak
I mean yeah
it was pretty creepy so uh so yeah now
Ginger is starting to like freak out
because he keeps doing that and it's
like not his voice and she's like um hey
what the [__] so she holds a cross up
and tries to exercise him or wake him up
or something
so Ray wakes up now Ray the the uh the
real guy was interviewed on the show too
and he said I don't remember [__] you
know what I mean he's like I woke up and
I just had like a little bit of a
headache and they were like what the
[__] was that all about and he's just
like what I don't know I don't know
so they actually did record him talking
they don't play the actual recording on
the show obviously because they never do
but they played it back for him and how
creepy would that be yeah like hearing
that like in your own voice but not like
saying that kind of [__] that you don't
remember that'd be pretty creepy but
yeah so they played it back for him and
he's just like what the [__] I don't
know what that I don't know what that is
he's like I don't even have any kids so
what the [__]
so at this point Rey finally admits what
happened at the house that scared him
out there so bad
he said he was in there working by
himself he heard somebody calling his
name which was the same thing that
Ginger had happened and then he heard
two gunshots downstairs
and he's he went down to see what the
noise was he's like I know that was
gunshots because he just got back from
Vietnam right and he smelled gunpowder
in the kitchen even though he saw the
bullet holes in the door but he's like
they were clearly old
yeah so he's like so I don't know what
the hell that was all about and then at
that point he turns around and he
apparently sees an apparition now on the
show they just showed him turning around
and then it was like you know ghost cam
like just coming at him and he's like ah
and then they cut to commercial right
now he said in another I saw another
thing about it and I don't know if he
said this or if it was in the book or
something like that but they said he saw
something that looked like
what do you say it looked like like a
rotting corpse or something like that
like he said something so he did
actually like see an apparition that
looked like a dead person or something
like that it wasn't just like a mist or
nothing
so um apparently
he okay so apparently Rey didn't know
the story about the Le Mans like
shooting at the ghost
prior to this
so he had been in the house he'd heard
two gunshots and then seeing the thing
and he told them about that and Raymond
was like oh my God that's like the story
that I heard from the neighbor like
where they shot at the ghost you know
what I mean so he was just like oh well
that checks out
so then Ginger decides she's gonna
hypnotize her dad
now while her dad is under hypnosis he
apparently has this Vision type thing
where he's in the house and he goes down
to the basement and he finds this little
wall cavity like behind there's like a
little rock that comes out and there's
like a little cavity behind there and
then there's a box in there
so he was doing some automatic writing
and ginger said it was really weird
because it seemed like he was writing
with a quill like he was pretending like
he was dipping the pen and the ink and
everything like an old like an old
school person would do
and what he writes is
um kind of like a land grant type thing
from like 1767 that was the date that he
wrote down
and he also wrote a name and that name
was Jonathan Carver
now after he wakes up he also doesn't
remember anything that he said and he's
freaked out that he saw that he wrote
all that stuff down
so they go to the library to research
this name now apparently allegedly uh
Jonathan Carver was kind of a well-known
Explorer in the area
who again allegedly brokered a piece
between two warring tribes of Native
Americans and he was gifted a large
parcel of land that included obviously
the land that Summer Wind sat on
so apparently this land grant it was
like a deed or something like that was
supposedly what was in this box and
their theory was that he was Haunting
the house because he was looking for the
[__] right
so they're like okay well even though
Jinger said I don't want to go over go
back to that [__] house ever again
but she's like we gotta go check and see
if that [__] is in the basement like you
said like you thought it was in your
vision so they go back to the house
now they go down to the basement and
they did find a space like behind like
they pulled a stone out where he dreamed
about it apparently and there is a
cavity back there but
there was nothing in there so you know
uh then they said they searched the
whole house after that but they never
could find that goddamn box or the deed
anywhere
and they said at this point they said
you know what
um you know all of our lives have been
kind of ruined by this [__] so maybe we
should just say [__] it so they just
said we're just gonna leave the house
and never come back did they sell it or
just abandon it well see I read that
somebody else bought it in 1983. okay
um but I'm assuming it was for sale
because like I said they sometimes
they're not real clear on the timeline
like because sometimes they they kind of
truncate a lot of um things into like a
short time period so it makes it seem
like oh it was just like six months or
something like that but then sometimes
it was like 10 years right and they
don't really tell you that but so I
don't really know like how long it was
empty the weird thing about it is that
they said when Ginger bought it they
said it had been empty 40 years but I
don't think it had been empty 40 years
because they bought it in 1969 and I
think the lamonts left
in
well no like Lamont died in 1948 and
they sold it then and then they like
another family lived in it after that so
it wasn't abandoned for 40 years like
when they bought it I'm just saying like
at least like according to what I
figured out
um so yeah uh lightning struck the house
or so they say or somebody burned it
down
in 1988. so uh so all that's there you
can still go there like a lot of
paranormal groups go there still
um pissing off the neighbors pissing off
the neighbors uh yeah all that's left is
just like the basement and like a couple
of the chimneys because that's all it
was Stone the rest of it was like the
basement was cool it's got arched
entryways in it kind of like an old
stable where you would I don't know
bring horses that look like yeah it was
converted probably to a garage probably
yeah
it is cool looking like I said I was
just watching some kind of more recent
videos where um where people were there
like I said paranormal groups love going
there because you know it's it's creepy
as [__] and everything like that so as I
mentioned this is okay now this is what
the history behind it was because now I
mentioned the lamonts right
House was built either 1916 or 1918 I've
seen both of those dates like I said it
was 80 acre property bloody black
um so
the um the servants that the lamonts had
they specifically said that they saw a
woman like a a translucent woman that's
what they called it like walking around
in the driveway that was what uh what
they saw
now uh obviously they reported that a
lot of times with the lamonts didn't
believe them until they actually saw you
know a man's Ghost come out the basement
and shot at him and blah blah and then
they left
now the property was vacant for a while
after that
um now the Lamont still owned the house
but nobody lived in it
now Lamont died in 1948.
and then the Mansion got sold a few
times but I guess nobody stayed that
long
and then the fan and then a family
called the kiefers bought it
now the woman in that family don't know
what her first name was she was just
called Mrs Kiefer
um they she moved into the house and she
started like not liking it she said I
just felt like I was being watched all
the time I think it's haunted and
apparently she when she left the house
because she was like [__] this place and
she left all her [__] in it so I I don't
know if that's true but that's something
that I heard that's why it was still
furnished in in a wreck yeah maybe all
her stuff yeah
so
yeah so like I said it hadn't been
abandoned for 40 years necessarily like
I think it had been abandoned before
1948 for a little while
but then somebody lived it like a couple
people lived in it and then they and
then the kiefers moved out and then
um the henshaws moved in in 1969
and then after that
um after the dad sold it they
it was purchased by a guy named Harold
Tracy and his wife Babs in 1986 Oh I
thought it was 1983 1986.
um and I don't know if
I'm assuming they were the ones that
owned it when it burned down
so uh because it burned down in 1988.
well several generations of people have
been in and out of that house and they
say that it's uh it's a bad house
uh yeah yeah it was probably a bad house
yeah yeah
now interestingly they actually because
I kind of feel like the popularity of it
now is probably because of that haunting
episode but in Wisconsin and actually
even kind of nationally this was known
as like a haunted house like before that
because they said Life Magazine did a
big
um kind of uh feature on it well it was
a feature about like the nine scariest
places in the United States or most
haunted houses or whatever and that was
back in 1980 so they mentioned it then
which and I'm assuming it looked I think
that's where the most popular like the
most famous photo of it comes from when
it looks like a dump I think that was
from 1980. if I if I'm not mistaken all
right so um so yeah so it was known as a
haunted house before that so like you
said you know uh all the local teenagers
because it's known as the haunted house
so everybody's gonna hang out in there
and smoke weed and
tell them stories and do all that other
kind of stuff
pentagrams and all that other kind of
[__] so so yeah you can kind of see it
was doing like a lot of vandalism and
all
that so uh yeah I've also heard a story
I don't know when this happens but one
story that I saw on one site said that
there were two teenage girls and they
were canoeing on the lake near the
Mansion when they actually saw
um a ghostly figure it was actually a
woman in white waving at them to come to
shore
and uh so they were like okay I wonder
what she wants so they they get up on
the beach in the canoe and they follow
her to the house and then they go inside
the house and then the woman disappeared
I don't know when that happened but that
was another uh story that I saw I don't
know if the Mansion was empty at that
time or what
so um so yeah so I guess that like I
said other people had seen like uh
apparitions around there and [__] like
that
so basically yeah I kind of feel like oh
one other thing that I figured and they
didn't mention this on the show either
and like I said this would have been
really interesting
um okay so there's two really creepy
things that they didn't mention on the
show
one
April the daughter she apparently uh
found a body
like a skeleton or a skeleton or a skull
I'm not sure like but in a crawl space
in the house what really didn't hear
that one yeah they didn't say that but
like some of the other sources I read
said yeah she said that they I don't
know why they were looking in the crawl
space or they found this crawl space it
was like a secret room or like a secret
closet or something like some [__] was
in front of it and like they opened it
now I've heard skull I've heard skeleton
okay so I don't know if it was like a
fold kind of thing right now here's
where it gets hanky though because they
said they found that and they were like
holy [__] there's like a [__] skull
they said it still had hair on it and
everything
and they never reported it
but apparently it disappeared like I
don't really know what happened to it I
remember that yeah because I think I
might have mentioned that on the last
one because I was like what the [__]
like why what happened to that head yeah
yeah where's that it was just
where's that severed head yeah you find
a head and a crawl space nobody needs to
know about that just gotta put that
right here on it and everything that's
nasty remember that head
no I'm not I don't think I don't think I
buy that I don't think I buy that either
maybe well maybe the maybe the makers of
a haunting girl they're like we're not
gonna talk about that because like oh
conveniently yeah conveniently we lost
at him
how do you lose a whole head yeah
how do you not call the cops that's what
I mean you would think that that would
be the first thing you would you would
do like if you found if I found a skull
in the wall yeah yeah because that could
be like somebody that's been missing for
a long time yeah holy [__]
um the other thing that they didn't
mention which like I said maybe they
thought this was a little too outlandish
was that Raymond and Rey the dad and the
Sun
they said that um because you know they
drew up blueprints because they were
gonna you know fix the house all up and
they were working on it and apparently
they would measure the rooms like to do
some work or something and then they
would come back the next day and the
room would be significantly larger or
significantly smaller than it was before
like the rooms would like change sizes
yeah I kind of suspect it's more like
not knowing how to [__] hold a tape
measure
I think that might I mean they were both
contractors you'd think that that would
be contracting 101 yeah but maybe not
maybe don't drink on the job kids
I don't remember how to use this tape
measures maybe it's more like uh wait
what was that reading
wait a minute what what dude wait is
this room eight feet or 80 feet
how do numbers
grab the other hand go back over here
rooms moving
is this room actually stretchy yeah yeah
yes he was I remember I remember these
little details that they're talking
about that kind of
kind of uh added to my skepticism about
the second part of the story right the
first part of the story seems more legit
the claims aren't as wild yeah because
they weren't well other than finding a
skull on the wall and not reporting it
is that from the first yeah because the
daughter supposedly found okay it wasn't
added in later I don't know I guess I
don't know certain elements may have
been I'll see all of these paranormal
stories they're just like so [__]
hard to yeah track down well because
they get repeated so many times like on
other paranormal websites and people add
details and all this other kind of stuff
speaking of which we started watching I
think one of you guys like warned us
about this but we started watching on
Netflix last night that 28 days haunted
thing yeah we had to change that [__]
yeah we didn't even get through the
first episode
I'm like this is dumb as hell yeah
ghost Brothers was better we'll see they
let you know that that was a comedy this
is post rednecks everybody's a redneck
in this one it's a whole [__]
which that's not a bad thing but I know
that they're marketing towards who
watches television that's or I think is
what you know I like the concept of it
like I like the concept of going to a
haunted place yeah yeah and making them
stay there like like it like in
isolation yeah for 28 days that's a cool
idea yeah
um you know but just in in practice it
wasn't really that interesting a bunch
of overweight Southern psychics going
did you hear that I heard that did you
hear that yeah I heard I kind of feel
like that's every single did you hear
that dude I heard that [__]
and then and then you know they're doing
that what's that what's that box thing
called that just goes through the radio
frequencies [__] box and they
imagine that they hear yeah the voices
coming through it I'm like yeah I'm
pretty sure that's just the radio yeah I
mean mango said I was at the haunted
Museum in Nottingham yesterday and got
to hold two human skulls that's pretty
neat one time I was at that um what do
they call that just the Bodies exhibit
where all the where all the body parts
are like you know they they preserved
them like with that weird plasticky
stuff and I got to like hold a human
brain so I thought that was like pretty
like a real human brain that was that
had been like all
plastid sized or whatever they call it
that was pretty cool actually yeah I
think I saw that in his Tampa
but uh but yeah so
I I like the idea of like the room's
getting but it's a very House of leaves
I'm into that but it's just kind of like
I don't think that really happened
because what
so I I kind of feel like that's maybe
why they didn't put it in the episode
yeah
and again with the skull thing because I
mean if they really found a skull and
they were like legit like called the
cops and stuff because you could check
that obviously the witness testimony for
the first part is pretty compelling
actually
because
the one that was the daughter yeah it
was a little girl yeah I kind of
believed her though they didn't let her
tell the entire story she's just chiming
in you know that he hated us there you
know just it's just kind of a
I don't know and her mom she seemed
pretty incredible they all kind of
seemed pretty credible yeah they didn't
seem like loons or like or anything they
just seemed like weird [__] right yeah
yeah and I'm not saying like some weird
[__] didn't happen that house it
probably did yeah but I don't know about
rooms changing sizes right and I don't
know what happened that's called and the
uh the dad he said some cool [__] which
which was true he's like you know how do
you deal with this where do you go
there's no book on any of this it's a
dimension we're talking about nobody
really knows that's absolutely true
nobody really knows no they don't know
how how hauntings and poltergeists don't
let [__] works you just observe it see
that's I think that's one of the things
you know going back to like when we
started watching 28 days haunted last
night that's what I don't like about a
lot of those haunting shows is that a
lot of them will come and they're very
authoritative yeah like we know how this
[__] works yeah oh well spirits will do
this that the other thing I'm like how
the [__] do you know no you don't know
what the [__] they're doing no knock it
off I mean I would have more respect for
them if they did believe that stuff but
then they just came in and said well I'm
not really sure but I think that blah
blah I mean that would be fine but don't
come in there and be like yeah this is
how this is how it goes and this is at
work because you don't [__] observed
me and my family or extended family and
my aunt and uncle at close rage observed
intense Poltergeist activity objects
[__] being thrown and I guess
teleported and [__] things stacked
and things arranged in patterns and
we saw it saw some of the stuff actually
move and we never could figure out how I
was doing it you know and
you never know for sure you know what I
mean [__] what it is you're dealing
with
um
or why or how but it's just
some kind of exotic physics
Stuart hammeroff stuff
yeah
but uh yeah it's cool though it does
exist
it's just nobody really knows everything
about it
yeah I wasn't quite sure what a
poltergeist could do even though I saw
it do a lot of different gags and it is
a trick somehow it really does do it
it's not an illusion but from its point
of view it's it's simple what it's doing
um it's not hard for it to do it
and there's and it was slowly getting
better at doing certain things it just
started to like mimic a voice
but I didn't want to hear that I ran
from that
just sounded like a bunch of garbled
yeah you don't want that [__] talking oh
you want to talking
yeah that's weird you zip your lip ghost
sorry I ain't talking to you bro
yeah Trey says uh Cindy Williams who was
Shirley on Laverne and Shirley uh also
just passed away okay that sucks
yeah that's really sad you getting
hungry Jim
uh yeah it's starting okay uh mango says
one of the skulls he was talking about
that he held apparently uh is apparently
haunted and attached to the person
certainly got some strange vibes from
holding it yeah that's uh that's pretty
cool I still wonder where that skull
went that from this house because what a
weird claim to make if you're just gonna
go and then I don't know where it went
yeah it's rage
must have left it on top of the car when
we drew him off or something I don't
know found this dead dude man he's gone
I'm not gonna say anything about it
sorry
be all right we're in the country
we're just gonna yeah maybe they just
didn't want to get the cops yeah or
maybe they did actually lose it it's
like where the hell did I put that down
it's like like animals got it left it
outside and the Animals got it yeah
maybe it's like ooh I'm having this yeah
all right all right so I guess we're
gonna wrap it up this was this was fun
to revisit this uh this is always a fun
gun we're gonna revisit hungry ghosts
with the girls being molested by the
Taiwanese ghosts and the [__] Shinto
or the Taoist priest I thought that was
cool as [__] we're gonna do that and
that was one of the few haunting
episodes that actually took place in
like another culture which I thought was
kind of cool because they don't really
do that too much I mean you know it's
not their fault I guess they got to work
with the stories they get but you know
what I mean so uh so yeah so we will be
back tomorrow evening doing a movie
review uh we're actually gonna be doing
the cult classic black comedy from the
1980s eating Raul so we're gonna be
watching that tonight and we're gonna be
talking about that tomorrow I haven't
seen it for like 30 years but I remember
like I can get very very much so uh so
yeah so thank you everybody for dropping
by thank you for becoming members you
guys and trying out my little emojis
that's like pretty cool yeah I haven't
seen the smell of sanctity one yet but
yeah yeah I think that one's I think
it's just like you know Colin's like
sanctity I think right it's at the end
of The Haunting when it's gone yeah
I was trying to find like a little like
some clip art that kind of looked like
Lorraine Warren but I was like I don't
have time to do that so I just put like
a [__] little rose on there but uh
but yeah so um yeah so we'll be back
tomorrow evening and we'll let you guys
know what's going on with scheduling and
stuff like that maybe I'll know more uh
tomorrow about how we're gonna Shuffle
the shows around and things like that uh
but yeah we'll see you guys again
tomorrow night have a good rest of your
evening you guys good night